what are some of the industries you're  most excited to see machine learning  applied or machine learning ethics  applied  yeah most excited  well i guess the health domain and the  assistant yeah mean  continue to be areas that i care a lot  about and i see a lot of good potential  yeah  i also really really want to be able to  have systems that assist people in terms  of understanding their own biases so  like there's lots of technology that's  being developed for like screening  candidates for job interviews and  things like that but really i feel like  the technology should be focusing on the  interviewer  and how they might be coming at the  situation with different biases and so i  would really love to have technology  that focuses more on  assisting humans to be more inclusive  as opposed to assisting humans to  exclude people